out of the two speakers
anna um she's been 2020 juggling being a
data scientist and being a mother to a
toddler
which anyone who's had a toddler has one
knows that's no
easy task full of energy and full of
disruption and destruction
all right and iman uh this
is a story back when she was going to be
an exchange student in hong kong she
kept looking to get a secondhand
bike but she uh couldn't find one it
wasn't until she moved there that she
realized why she couldn't find one
and i'm going to guess the answer is
because of all the hills in hong kong
um hong kong's very famous for the hills
which makes for dramatic skylines
and it's awesome but it uh
makes it very hard to bike so please
welcome to the stage
anna and iman so hello
thank you very much uh for giving us the
chance to
present our work here um
i'm adamantly i'm a data scientist here
at find
and i am iman al-idrissi a junior dieter
scientist also at find
uh so today we're going to talk to you
about our fine source cove tool tracker
for our testing data um it has been
really unprecedented here if we might
say
because it certainly uh feels that our
world has stopped on its tracks after
experiencing this pandemic uh certainly
this is not the first time that the
world is experiencing pandemics
um there was the spanish group for
example in 1918
but i guess there are not many people
here in the audience that they have a
firsthand
experience on this um but back then
around the
one third of the world's population
actually i was infected at the time
uh but one might argue that there are
two
two key differences right now uh firstly
we actually have a truly global economy
where international travel
and you know habits on our getting our
food from
all over the world i would allow kobe 19
to spread
much rapidly much more rapidly and also
we actually
have the tools like modern medicine and
data access to be used in sophisticated
sort of modeling techniques in order to
fight this
and allow the countries to track the
pandemic but even though this is a
global pandemic
unfortunately still was tackled in
national levels as we've seen
and it sometimes it was heavily
politicized and
science was sometimes ignored as well um
so since the beginning of the pandemic
the
wgl director dr andrews which
who you might be familiar with now
has actually spread the message of test
test tests
and but why is retesting really
important
um testing is actually our main tool
in order to combat this pandemic it can
actually help us
contact do contact tracing and isolation
of the confirmed cases
it has been actually preliminary results
show that one death of around a thousand
health workers screens can be averted
and actually using the right numbers
it can inform policy decisions but
cases hospitalizations and death data
unfortunately unfortunately they're easy
to obtain
but because they're quite visible um but
testing data is not they are a bit more
abstract
and even though they're they should be
used in order to inform the metrics on
positivity rates on infection rates
in order to help us reopen our economies
so at a very very early stage of
the pandemic it became clear to
everybody that testing was important
from patients to healthcare workers
including policymakers and governments
however it was clear that there was no
authority taking care of the worldwide
testing
coverage reporting and neither
guiding all the countries of the world
on
standards on how to report their testing
data
so you've probably seen many of these
dashboards describing the global
pandemic
and this is just an example of the word
health organization
dashboard they display many different
epidemiological data describing the
dynamic
you have like cases and death numbers
but unfortunately the
test numbers are missing this is a
global pandemic
and we live in a globalized world look
at us here in geneva
we basically cross the border between
switzerland
and france several times a day without
even noticing these
it is really important to be able to
have a global overview
of the testing coverage for compute 19.
and this was missing and we
really identify the gap here but
fortunately
there are solutions and we have people
believing in those solutions
and this is why anna and me are here
today
so we both work at the foundation for
innovative new diagnostics
it is a non-profit organization in
global health that was established
during the
56th world health assembly in 2003
so our mission is to make diagnostics
for infectious diseases
available everywhere including for
people in low and middle-income
countries
and in order to achieve that we partner
and we build projects by partnering with
the
public and private sector so we work on
different diseases for example
tuberculosis
or malaria and we also work on pandemic
preparedness in general
and this is why we got involved in the
act
a which means access to khabib 19
accelerator tools accelerator so it is
a global collaboration to accelerate the
development
production and equitable access to kobe
19 tools
and there are three pillars the vaccines
killer
the therapeutics killer and of course
the diagnostic skill
which is where um find intervenes
but in order to properly fulfill our
role in the axe accelerator
it was important to have to know
how well the countries in the whole
world
how well they were doing in terms of the
testing coverage
and since that was missing we
tried to investigate country by country
so some countries decided to group their
data
for example we have here the dashboard
from the africa cdc
and they showed a very good
example here so we have um
epidemiological data on kv19
for old african countries including
the number of tests
other countries
unfortunately didn't decide to put
together their data
and it almost looked like a competition
for
the fanciest and the most colorful
dashboard so we have three examples here
qatar switzerland and sri lanka
as you can notice they have uh they
report
daily numbers for kobe 19 testing
and um they report in a precise and
structured way um and also we can see
that their dashboards are actually
in english although their official
languages are not necessarily english
other countries didn't think of that so
there is clearly great effort put
in formulating daily reports
describing the national situation
about the kobe 19 pandemic
but unfortunately we can clearly see
that the people behind these reports
they didn't think of the accessibility
of their data
so it's all greek to me is basically
the sentence i told and now when i was
desperately trying
to localize the testing numbers
in this ptf all written in the week
and fortunately she is from greece and
you know this is quite representative of
geneva and the foundation for innovative
new diagnostics because
it is a multicultural environment
and we have people coming from many
different countries
and speaking so many different languages
and thanks to this great diversity
we were able to basically
find all the testing data from the
different countries of the world
um so at this stage
the data team has find decided to build
a global
tracker for for the the testing coverage
of kobe 19 and anna will tell you more
about
the whole story yes thank you man so
initially
um having this very ambitious time we
tried to show the global picture
and we had to put together a dashboard
um
like everyone was doing in the beginning
of the pandemic
in a very short time uh unfortunately
things and decisions were not taken
that's you know
thinking the outcome and that picture
was taking a long time to load
um some of the problems were that
because of the data were scraped
minorly from each website report twitter
report facebook report you might
imagine and we were putting lots of time
and effort on this every day
then all the databases that are using
the shiny app
they were actually generated by the
shiny app actually slowing down the
application significantly
and then like countries sometimes
we also didn't think of the end user and
that some users might need to use our
data for their projects
so it was not very easy to retrieve them
for good programmatically
uh unless it was not very user friendly
from the feedback that we got because
there were too many tabs and
users were getting quite lost with all
this information
so we decided to actually fix some of
the problems
and we developed and designed fed fetch
functions in our
in order to parse these websites and
reports and
from the countries that were actually at
least reporting it in
you know in a place that we could
retrieve
and then we actually generated in our
package where we put together
the generation of the data sets
and got we created um and
github repository where we were pushing
every day all the data
sets produced uh also we uh got
an article like app feeling and we
shaped our application
demand will go further with the fetch
functions
so um from the diversity
in the different ways the countries
actually report their data
we found some similarities and we then
grouped
them and we assigned different types to
the different groups
so some countries were assigned the type
html other is the type pdf
and for more complex countries we
decided to use selenium
so we have an selenium script
that scrapes the data of some countries
and then
we generate a text file containing
discrete data
we have our street
that goes country by country
and according to the type the country
has been assigned the our script uses
what we call fetch functions and
it uses the corresponding fetch function
so for example
if the country has the type html the r
script will use the
fetch from html function and if it's
selenium it will be fetched from
selenium and then read the text file so
we end up every day with a file
containing
all the testing data so the cumulative
and the new tests per day and then we
put
this file we push it on github
and anna will explain you how then from
his head this is
actually put in our test tracker
so as soon as a man pushes the file on
github this triggers an automated
workflow
um for with github actions
that actually executes the three main
functions
of our our package
which is a process jbl data which is
actually function
taking together the cases and that's
data from the johns hopkins repository
uh and creates the chronovirus
underscore cases
file then we have the process test data
which creates a coronavirus underscore
test.csv
and the create shiny data which combines
both of these datasets in order to
create
the data shiny dataset which is then
used by the shiny app
all these three datasets are updated a
daily under found on our find commenting
tracker data repository on github
um then we actually reshape
the we said before we wanted it to be
a bit more like to have a an article
live
feeling so the user can go through all
the different visualizations etc i'll
show you in a bit
um we basically use the tabler dash r
package in order to enclose
the fluid row layout and we used for
the e-charts for our
functions in order to render our
visualizations for the map and the
time series uh also we use um a
global.rt where we put together all our
helper
functions uh in order to read the file
from our github
repository and filter it in order to be
used in the shiny app
so i will show you very very fast a sort
of
preview uh of our um
tracker it's found on our it's embedded
on our main
uh find websites uh here we you can see
that we have the
testing coverage um and some
sorry we have detailed instructions on
how to
use the application uh the user can
actually select the different
outcomes test cases that's positivity
rate
their totals for uh daily and committed
data
and per capita in total so for uh
to show you how a user can get a very
fast insight on the data
uh since iman said before that our
mission is to show
data um especially if coverage is enough
and equitable of testing
we want to show that there is a clear
difference of
testing coverage between high income and
low-income countries
you can clearly see it here on the map
um
there in africa south america and
southeast asia
test capacity is far less far lower than
the
actually in north america europe etc
and the user can get actual you know
visualization of this
uh straight away uh here we compare the
data by country
continent or income group the user can
actually sort and choose the different
categories that we put together i will
quickly
select high income countries and low
income countries which is also an input
for
our um track change over time
time series graph uh it's an insurance
crap so
you can clearly track the pandemic and
you can see that there is a striking
difference between the number of pests
performed
in high income countries and low income
countries
so we wanted to get across these
measures really really clearly
and then we can have our the data
downloaded either for
the selection that was not involved or
the user can actually go through the
same
link to our github repository
so um now
what are the next steps for us um
more and more countries are actually
deploying the use of
rapid diagnostic tests which is
different from pcr tests
and it's really important to be able to
discriminate between those two type of
tests
so because we really want our tracker to
respond
to to the to what is needed to
tackle the pandemic we want to go and
evolve along
the pandemic and we will definitely
start soon
segregating data between rapid
diagnostic tests
and pcrs within our tracker we would
also
like to include the number of idps
procured per country since it is also
a very important information and at this
stage we still have
some countries for which the tasting
data is taken
manually and we obviously would like to
automate
um also for those countries probably we
will use
cli selenium and github actions because
it's easy to maintain and less resource
reliance
so all in all these tools have actually
enabled us
to access the data that were very scarce
and you know
they were all over the place basically
in multiple websites
um unlike the case data
so they allowed us to actually have
access to these when we
had really many constraints of time
and resources here in clients and we
needed to produce
a very high standard web application to
put there out there in our website
in order to add value on import on the
importance of the testing data during
this pandemic
um we would really we would really like
to highlight that this
testing data etc should be really
important
and should have you know their open
access
sort of repository um no matter
if you have an outbreak or endemic but
in general in order to
sort of inform surveillance and
epidemiological efforts to import
research and have really evidence-based
policy decisions and also we need to
have
orchestrated efforts from governments
other authorities such as ministries of
health etc
to produce this sort of machine readable
data and open access in repositories
where
uh researchers can use them um you know
very very fast
and we would like to help our colleagues
here in find uh christine um stefano and
governor
and of course we would like to have
patrick and christoph from syncra
that have helped us reshape our
obligation and last
andrew that helped us put together these
lines in order to get across our message
better
thank you very much thank you
excellent talk uh continuing along our
day
and our next speaker